[Music]
starring in our Saturday session this
morning phoebe Bridgers the los
angeles-based singer-songwriter got our
attention a year ago in the form of a
heads-up tweet famed musician Ryan Adams
alerted us last year before her debut
record was out saying quote this new
record she made is going to be a modern
masterpiece
you'll hear Phoebe perform in just a
moment but first we caught up with her
at the Gibson guitar showroom here in
New York
[Music]
2017 was a breakout year for 23 year old
Phoebe printers your album ended up on a
lot of urine best of the Year lists yeah
it was awesome was cool it was really
for me it's time you heard her John
Mayer tweeted in December this is the
arrival of a giant I've been talking to
his dead it makes me so sad when I think
too much about I can't breathe raised in
Pasadena California richer started
writing songs when she was 15
so what made you pick up a guitar I was
obsessed with yoni Mitchell and Jackson
Browne and I just totally romanticized
that as a thing to do with my life
she started performing at the Folk Music
Center in Claremont California owned by
Ben Harper and his family they haven't
opened mic every month and that's where
I played my first like original song she
was driven to those open mic nights by
her mom Jamie who's her biggest fan she
makes fun of me because I used to call
her overly supportive she's like how is
that possible for a mother yes yeah I
apparently went when I was a toddler
before I could even say words my grandma
told my mom that when I hummed I sound
like Bonnie Raitt so exact is any
indication about overly supportive what
I might have meant it's that they would
love to hear that yeah
when you started playing where were you
what we you aspiring to I've always
wanted to sound like myself I like
having something to show for a certain
time in my own life where does this song
begin for you I have kind of a ongoing
iphone note where I write cool little
phrases or stuff that I hear throughout
the day it usually starts with a phrase
or a little melody sometimes I miss hear
music in the grocery store or something
and I'll realize oh that's cool though
what it's not it's cool Georgia Georgia
I love you when did you feel like you'd
settle down the style of your home when
he gets older might be the I don't know
if I have yet which is cool I want to be
one of those artists that like I could
release an electronic record or a
country record next and nobody would be
surprised